[Music]
there's more to war than just weapons
and politics ace combat is a series that
showed us just that hitting its stride
in the early 2000s with an enchanting
mix of jet fighting and human melodrama
but in the past decade its entries
suffered from putting less importance on
in signature stories it dropped four
games worth of fictional law in favor of
real-world locations traded pathos
formic yzma and attempted to add
cinematic blockbuster bombast to the
clinical nature of flying jets all at
the cost of losing its identity
thankfully Ace Combat 7 Skye's unknown
brings the series back on course and is
a significant return to what it was in
its prime a thrilling interpretation of
modern aerial combat that also tells a
war story with heart a conscience and
personal stakes the narrative of skies
are known dives back into the fictional
series universe last seen in 2007 and
deals with the conflict between the
familiar powers of the ocean federation
and the kingdom of Arusha you play a
silent faceless ocean pilot who will go
through some changing allegiances but
half of the plot actually occurs in
cinematics that run parallel to and
separate from your actual missions and
come from the perspective of seemingly
minor plays around the periphery it's a
war story that pivots with the actions
of its small cast of characters as much
as it does military victories and leans
heavily into themes of the human
condition the graves of fabricated ideas
like nationality borders and cultural
identity as well as the ethics of
advancements in technological warfare to
be clear there aren't many nuanced
discussions to be had between the
pronounced personalities of the cast
this is a drama first and foremost radio
chatter is filled with bold statements
of ideology
and sometimes it feels like there's a
naivety in the writing for entirely
different slightly juvenile reasons how
penal is this penal unit you ask this
place is a [ __ ] it's regularly hammy
and melodramatic but the entire endeavor
is so wide-eyed and earnest so
enduringly heartfelt and ultimately
optimistic in nature that it's easy to
let yourself be swept up and moved by it
all larger-than-life voices amp you up
over the radio when you're flying into a
Saudi adding an infectious passion to
affairs they remind you what you're
fighting for and sometimes make you feel
bad and question your actions the
overlapping conversation would be a
little distracting when you're trying to
dodge a missile but it's that vital
human element that keeps you really
invested in this game about shooting
down planes but that's not to say that
the aerial combat in ace combat 7 is
anything but superb the fundamental
actions of chasing down enemies at high
speeds out maneuvering them to line up a
clear shot or banking hard to avoid an
incoming missile while your dashboard
beeps and flashes wildly at you is
enough to keep you on the edge of your
seat constantly your focus lies solely
on your plane and your surroundings
there's a variety of familiar factors to
take into consideration while flying but
a significant new element is clouds and
the tangible risks and possibilities
they invite juking into a bank of clouds
can break missile locks and give you the
element of surprise but come at the cost
of reduced visibility the possibility of
icing up your plane and hindering
maneuverability and even things like
strong wind currents and lightning
strikes messing with your ability to
keep control of your jet clouds are
legitimately useful strategic
considerations on top of just being a
pretty thing to admire and they make the
skies of Ace Combat 7 a more interesting
place to be there's also an impressive
variety of distinct scenarios across the
game's 20 campaign missions generally
the scope of most battles are quite
large and require you to split your
attention between different kinds of
skirmishes across the map with a broader
objective in mind but many missions also
come with unique challenges that make
for some memorable moments dogfighting
in a thunderstorm at night stealth
Canyon runs an avoiding huge area of
effect blasts in the middle of a busy
battle are some enjoyable standouts
the game's few boss style encounters are
a highlight - as you go
against impossibly good a spiders and
the game's white whale super weapon
there are a few scenarios that aren't as
exciting however hunting the trucks in a
sandstorm and chasing ICBMs grew tiring
pretty quickly and the game's final
challenge is a tricky exercise in plane
maneuvering that feels like it
necessitates multiple retries by design
which puts a damper on an otherwise
grand finale
the act of retrying will inevitably come
with a pang the resentment to since
checkpointing in skies are known is
sparse checkpoints typically only occur
at the halfway point of a mission and
it's common to get twenty minutes into a
battle before failing to hit an
objective and having to start from the
very beginning this can get frustrating
in the tail into the campaign where
threats are more abundant and moral
endless and the overall demands are
higher granted there is a lightning
versus on score performance and your
mission score persists even if you need
to retry from the halfway point but a
little more generosity wouldn't have
gone astray Ace Combat 7 features are
straightforward peer to peer online
multiplayer component featuring 8 player
deathmatch and team deathmatch modes
dogfighting with other human beings is
certainly a lot more challenging and
phonetic and because matches are only 5
minutes in length they consistently feel
fast paced and full of excitement the
planes and equipment you unlock as part
of the campaign carry over to
multiplayer and vice versa but
everything has an assigned value and
you're able to play matches that have a
limit on how much you can bring which
helps keep a level playing field online
sorties also feature a weighted scoring
system where leading players are clearly
marked and have a higher score value
attached to their destruction in my
experience it's an idea that works well
in practice stopping you from being a
target if you're doing poorly and
keeping you on your toes if you're doing
well the PlayStation 4 version of skies
are known also features an exclusive VR
mode consisting of an Ace Combat 4
inspired mini campaign there are only 3
missions and their objectives are less
complicated than those of the main
campaign but even so the experience of
flying from the cockpit of a plane is
engrossing the feeling of speed and
height is literally dizzying the ability
to freely look around and track a target
with your gaze is terrific and the
active pitching and rolling your plane
is so effective at eliciting a feeling
of actual g-force and I personally had a
hard time doing more than one mission at
once without breaking out into a
nauseous sweat it's a shame that there's
no option to play the main campaign in
VR the head tracking and free look alone
would be incredibly useful but the mode
is a great addition nonetheless good
aerial combat is important for a game
involving jet fighters but it's a given
quality for ace combat skies are known
burst a beautiful photo realistic world
entertaining mission variety and a
reason to get excited about clouds but
most importantly it carries a
you devotion to the history and stories
of its fictional universe and with that
it brings back the human emotional
center that makes it remarkable Ace
Combat 7 is a fantastic return for a
series that is at its best when it wears
its heart on its wings I've gone from
being a little girl to well still a girl
just older but now I was all alone
wherever the souls of my gramps and his
pals are flying
I hope it's peaceful
[Music]
you